dans une banlieue de madrid un père et
son fils joue au foot
lève toi ne va pas trop vite chaud allez
tire plus fort une fin d'après-midi
banal en famille mais osama et saïd ne
sont pas des amoureux du ballon rond
tout à fait comme les autres
soudain des avions militaires passent
dans le ciel papa tu as vu des avions de
chasse
il y a des hélicoptères et des ming ne
t'en fais pas aïd
il croit que ce sont des mig des mig les
avions militaires russes utilisé par le
dictateur syrien bachar el assad le père
et le fils se sont échappés de l'enfer
de la guerre en syrie et ce jour là les
préparatifs du défilé aérien pour la
fête nationale espagnole
les renvois de mauvais souvenirs ils
veulent comme ça très bas ne se seraient
pas des mygales je t'ai dit que les mig
c'était juste en syrie
aujourd'hui le monde entier connaît les
réfugiés osama et saïd à cause de ça le
croche pied d'une journaliste hongroise
[Musique]
un geste incompréhensible qui va
déclencher une chaîne de solidarité
phénoménale au point d'arracher osama et
saïda leur calvaire tout a commencé le 8
septembre 2015 à rusk à la frontière
entre la serbie et la hongrie
les policiers hongrois ont reçu l'ordre
de stopper les migrants des milliers
d'entre eux sont bloqués ici alors
qu'ils veulent gagner l'allemagne
soudain ils forcent le passage et fonce
droit devant tu c'est à ce moment là que
se produit l'impensable une journaliste
hongroise ici à l'image en chemise bleue
se met à distribuer des coups de pied
aux migrants y compris aux enfants
osama id ici à l'image sont là eux aussi
alors qu'ils tentent d'échapper à un
policier
elle tend la jambe et fait chuter osama
qui porte son fils dans les bras le
petit saïd est choqué
[Musique]
ces images ont fait le tour du monde en
espagne
le président d'un centre de formation de
football se rend compte qu sam à l
entraîneur d'une équipe de foot syrienne
de première division
bouleversés par les images il envoie
l'un de ses adjoints un footballeur
arabophone chercher oussama et le petit
saïd qui entre-temps se sont réfugiés en
allemagne
huit jours après le croche pied il
arrive à madrid
[Applaudissements]
ils sont enfin en sécurité
et son bienfaiteur espagnol lui en plus
offert un contrat de travail et un
logement pour sa famille je vous aime
j'aime madrid j'aime l'espagne toute
l'espagne merci pour tout c'est un
moment très important dans ma vie
le réfugié syrien ne s'attendait
vraiment pas à un tel accueil
sa nouvelle vie prend racine ici à
getafe une ville populaire de la
banlieue de madrid
au pied de son immeuble
nous retrouvons osama avec mohamed son
deuxième fils qui était réfugié en
allemagne depuis huit mois
ce matin-là ils ont rendez vous avec
sanaa leur professeur d'espagnol trois
fois par semaine osama la reçoit chez
lui dans le grand appartement familial
payé par son employeur
dès la casta bbbb npt la leçon du jour
énoncé son numéro de téléphone
un vrai défi d'un tcc fat et au début
c'était très compliqué mais maintenant
je commence à comprendre un peu à
bondues comprends qu'on prend un tout
petit peu c'est lui qui comprend rien
alors c'est tous les deux pas de
programme imposé sanaa enseigne les
bases en fonction des besoins et parfois
de l'humeur vous n'oubliez pas de faire
vos devoirs pour demain s'ils font leurs
devoirs et qu'ils étudient sérieusement
il va vite être capable de communiquer
qu'est ce que tu as dit est à bienne
c'est ça oui est à vienne c'est correct
bravo il leur faudra du temps avant de
maîtriser la langue
en attendant osama et mohamed fils à
l'école du quartier récupérer zaid osama
est un peu inquiet
c'était aujourd'hui son premier jour
d'école salut mon grand
ce matin il pleurait mais là ça a l'air
d'aller je suis content saïd connaît
déjà quelques mots d'espagnol
voilà
sergio ramos le joueur du real madrid tu
as essayé de parler avec les autres
élèves non m'ont beaucoup parlé mais
j'ai rien compris
marisol la maîtresse l'arrivée de zai
dans la classe a été l'occasion d'un
cours de géographie bible au début ça a
été dur pour le monde pleurait et moi on
a parlé de ce qui se passe dans son pays
et on a repéré la syrie sur la carte
avec les copains tu t'en souviens qu'il
y aura des mails pattes
après il a voulu jouer au ballon dans
windows est bon les aïds à demain allez
dire au revoir à ta professeurs
dès le premier jour devant l'école la
famille syrienne ne passe pas inaperçu
ici tout le monde connaît son histoire
[Musique]
s'ils sont vraiment tous gentils ils
sont très chaleureux
ils me proposent leur solide est
redevenu un enfant ordinaire mais il ya
encore une ombre au tableau sa mère est
toujours bloquée dans un camp de
réfugiés en turquie avec ses deux autres
frères
elle était malade et n'a pas pu suivre
ça m'a aidé à id selon la loi espagnole
osama ne pourra faire venir sa femme que
dans un an même si avec l'aide de son
employeur il se démène pour les
accueillir plus tôt le petit garçon
réclament de plus en plus amer
tous les jours le père et le fils
l'appelle au téléphone un rituel
important de la journée
en attendant sont arrivés petit à petit
osama essayent de reconstruire une vie
de famille pour ses enfants mais tu me
fait mal aux oreilles
c'est la semaine de tous les changements
pour osama après la première matinée
d'école de son fils il doit maintenant
affronter une autre grande nouveauté il
part travailler le centre de formation
d'entraîneur qui l'a embauché est à 10
minutes à pied de chez lui vous savez je
ne me suis jamais vraiment arrêté de
travailler
je n'avais pas de salaire pour ça mais
en turquie où j'étais avant de venir ici
j'ai monté une équipe avec des joueurs
syrien a appelé l'équipe de l'espoir
bonjour bonjour
osama est accueilli par ses nouveaux
collègues et le directeur de cette
entreprise qui forme chaque année 4000
entraîneur bouleversée par les images du
croche-pied conrad au et son frère ont
offert un poste à ossama dès qu'ils ont
appris qu'il était entraîneur en syrie
[Musique]
on n'avait pas de commercial pour
travailler avec les clubs arabes alors
au sam a été la personne parfaite
ils parlent la langue il a de
l'expérience
un diplôme d'entraîneur il a gagné une
coupe dans son pays et surtout il est
d'origine arabe donc c'est parfait pour
nous sans hésiter conrad au a organisé
le rapatriement de sama en quelques
heures seulement on dit que le visage
est le reflet de l'âme pas vrai on le
voit tout de suite c'est un père de
famille normal il a traversé des guerres
on voit que c'est une bonne personne
il verse un salaire de 1200 euros par
mois osama en plus de la prise en charge
de son logement et de ses cours
d'espagnol
il compte sur la grande popularité des
entraîneurs ibérique très demandé par
les clubs arabes pour rentabiliser son
investissement pour le moment osama est
chargé de vendre des sessions de
formation d'entraîneur à ses clubs et de
contacter des footballeurs arabophone
qui seraient susceptibles de venir jouer
en espagne
j'ai des contacts en jordanie au liban
en irak en arabie saoudite
ce jour là s'appelle omar sow masse et
assyriens il m'a envoyé un message parce
qu'on se connaît bien je les entraînais
quand il était jeune il jouait dans mon
club à deir ezzor est aujourd'hui c'est
le meilleur buteur d'arabie saoudite
vous avez envie d'entraîner un club
espagnol oui il le faut
c'est mon objectif il faut que je
redevienne entraîneur je suis sur le bon
chemin
je vais y arriver osama commencera à
retravailler sur les terrains de foot
quand il maîtrisera sa nouvelle langue
[Musique]
le lendemain nous le retrouvons pour un
nouveau cours d'espagnol
cette fois-ci sanaa a décidé de
l'immerger dans la ville il commence par
un magasin
[Musique]
et après professeur professeur officer
sanaa vous pouvez venir
highco et 16 et ça ce serait bien pour
saïd pour l'école le cartable bleu quoi
ici oui il est très bien
il en a profité pour acheter un cartable
pour son fils comme n'importe quel père
de famille et maintenant direction le
kiosque à journaux
osama s'informent régulièrement de
l'évolution de la situation dans son
pays en guerre
deir ezzor c'est là où j'habitais après
on est parti à jaca et on est passés en
turquie aujourd'hui sa ville sa maison
sont occupées par les combattants de
dèche
comment dit-on réfugiés en espagnol
c'était pouvant table de voir tous ces
migrants ça me rend triste tous ces gens
qui fuient leur pays
grosse colère
osama à quitter la syrie quand le régime
de bachar el-assad a bombardé sa ville
il n'est pas certain aujourd'hui d'y
retourner un jour
[Musique]
allez on prend un petit déjeuner un
petit déjeuner sur une terrasse au
soleil
l'occasion de découvrir la tap à la plus
célèbre d'espagne
c'est une tortilla
il ya des pommes de terre des oeufs et
un peu d'oignons
après les horreurs de la guerre
osama profite de chaque instant de sa
nouvelle liberté
mais le conte de fées ne sera parfait
que lorsque sa femme leur a rejoint en
espagne
[Musique]